vous avez un incroyable talent on dit là
bas qu'est ce que vous avez un truc
carole ce que tu a un incroyable talent
toi la voix vincent l habitat bois c'est
non non non si basso j'espère je sais
pas je vous aurais peut-être d'autres
talents oui c'est ce qui nous attend ici
on n'a pas des talents de ouf c'est naze
mais non lié mon oreille 8 voici leaf
c'est au buzzer tu sais payer ton
oreille au mythe
oui mais c'est dingue mathieu le roux
fait la même chose des leçons c'est avec
les pièces aussi la cote c'est faire
passer des pièces surtout un regard
devait faire le temps alors j'ai fait la
danse du ventre
ouais je suis là depuis que ouais t'as
rôle c'est quoi ton incroyable talent a
rien d'incroyable talent ici mathieu
animateur bardot comme un truc qu'on a
vu en quelques clics et voilà qu'on peut
juger alors nos silos et le reste bien
vous l'avez pas vu mais j'espère vous le
verrez un jour non
ah bon sexuelle beaucoup d'émoi je le
verrai jamais kelly peut-être me
raconteras ou le sait pas vous êtes
traité les gens pleurer d'émotion pour
de vrai je tairai les noms sur les gens
pleurer parce que vous les barriques de
personnes personnes intègres et allons
annoncer qu'on appelle à l'anglais
autant garder attendait voilà ne sont
pas du tout attendez du coup mais qu'est
ce que la pâte ou 19 ans je vais je vous
le dis franchement moi je vais prendre
mes cliques
j'en ai trop c'est trop je fais vomir il
alors mon canon imitateur je suis hyper
bien patrimoine anglais 123 c'est vrai
je suis champion du monde double et
j'arrive à mettre des goûts réjouit
patrick wyatt avancées comme les frères
jacques à ouais ouais merci à une
chanson sur l'air d'une autre chanson il
ya une inversion cérébrale
[Rires]
merci isabelle merci pour le compliment
personne d'autre talent du magnétisme
l'armée je guéris les personnes qui ont
de la fièvre généralement ah non en fait
non c'est vraiment ils ont trait choses
nous ont dit de partir c'est tout
n'avait pas si vous voulez que je
refasse limitation de l'otarie mais
j'arrive à m'endormir minutes battant
oui ouais j'aime bouger mes oreilles
asie ah ouais d'accord la carole elle a
trouvé un talon ah oui c'est vrai et
c'est faire les défauts à
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais ce voile alerte morandini jean marc
c'est énorme
la dragonne jean-marc a émis une alerte
carole rousseau tu sais très bien les
regarder jegaseelan rôle à elle le fait
divers bien